I can't believe I'm watching the final
she's mrs. stark MJ MJ called me magic
kid goes for Tim Duncan Lee's right over
there snow geese these are for you
what you wanted to watch the game my
change finally here we go
good evening Peter oh you have 576
possible well shooter from the nation ha
ha ha
I can keep that suit yeah doesn't fit me
where's our next retreat
what next mission we'll call you all
right that's not a hug then just grab
the top for you all right there yet
all right kid good luck out there
hey Peter you coming tonight I can't
tonight I got the astark internship
what's up guys
mr. stuff here's my report for tonight I
stopped the grand theft bicycle hey
could you do me a favor hold on to that
there's anybody by oh I helped us old
lady and she bought me a churro
so how was nice I just feel like I could
be doing more wait a minute you guys on
the real event just hope gives it away
new move I'm working on
he's working for crazy dangerous listen
there are people who handle the sort of
thing can't you just be a friendly
neighborhood spider-man
activating parachute
the world's changing boys time we change
to my chance to prove myself we have a
Spanish quiz you gotta get better at
this part of the job
I'm Sam oh I'm intimidated
where you going what are you hiding
Peter I'm just getting younger by
there's a ton of other subsystems in
here but they're all disabled by the
training wheels protocol I'm sick of mr.
stark treating me like a kid but you are
a kid yeah you can stop a boss with his
bare hands
[Music]